this movie was so weird too scared the
hair right off of my face
no this is where the it reviews so don't
worry it's gonna come back I'm gonna
grow it back but yeah I just saw the
movie mother explanation point it
definitely deserves that explanation
point even the title says mother it
fades away and that the explanation
point is still there the fades away so
it's it's a way it really needs that
explanation point um I'm just gonna give
me a heads up this is probably gonna be
my asshole review I just know as soon as
I give this review people are gonna be
like what an asshole but just bear with
me a little bit but I gotta go into
spoilers to talk about it so pre spoiler
anything I'm not gonna go into details
or anything like that because everyone
says you should go in knowing nothing
about this film and that's kind of true
so here's my initial thoughts uh I like
the way it's written surprisingly I
really like the way this movie is
written I don't like the way it's
directed and I really like this guy's
work this is Darren Aronofsky and he's
done a lot of really riveting strange
surreal gritty interesting movies and
this one I felt while well was written
nice he wrote it as well uh I thought I
thought it was not interesting to look
at I don't feel with the exception of
maybe Michelle Pfeiffer all the
performances are good they're good
performances but but nothing really
stands out in something that where the
characters are written kind of vaguely
if that's a maybe I don't know again I
can't really talk about what going to
spoilers but performances are fine but
okay here's the thing
everyday guy wakes ups
asked the cinematographer what do you
think we should shoot today and said
well well let's shoot all our actors
particularly Jennifer Lawrence like this
and he said brilliant next shot what we
gonna do well why don't we shoot all our
actors particularly Jennifer Lawrence
like this that is the goddamn movie and
here's the thing as it goes on and on
those shots are needed because they're
supposed to build the anxiety and stuff
but the whole movie is shot like that so
I don't know why
to be a movie I think this could have
been a play I don't know why
what cinematic big screen elements this
adds that you couldn't probably also get
on stage III think this would be a
wonderful play I think you could totally
do it over I am again without going
displayers am I glad I saw it sure it's
one of those movies where I'm kind of
like yeah this is a good idea is some
see to me some parts have too much
detail but it is left just vague enough
where I feel like okay you can serve
read different things into it and the
performances are good and when these to
be very anxiety-provoking it is other
people ask is it a horror film
in the same way eraser heads a horror
film you know it's like technically yeah
but the really shocking disturbing stuff
everyone's talking about that's what
really happen until the last I don't
know 15 minutes something like that
so is it Gauri's that all that stuff
again not until the end so if you're
thinking this whole movie is gonna be
shocking and disturbing it just really
hammering it out the whole way through
it really doesn't get there until the
end and you'll get it yeah you know they
they definitely pile it all on but so if
you're looking for something that
abstract and definitely provokes a lot
of anxiety and can be open to
interpretation this will work for you I
think it'll work okay
my initial problems with some of you are
gonna find hard to believe is that
sometimes I think it hammer the nail a
little too much on the head and now we
gotta go into spoiler territory okay cuz
none of you are gonna believe me on this
I I put this on my facebook I've even
seen the reactions yet I know they're
saying you you goddamn liar but I swear
to God one of my major problems with
this movie is it was kind of predictable
I know you're like what the hell are you
talking about you goddamn liar but I
will tell you exactly how I I could kind
of figure out what was gonna
it didn't necessarily ruin the movie but
but it it gotten away a little bit um
alright so we're in spoiler territory
now to just hopefully get an idea before
you know if this is a movie you wanna
see or not so okay movie opens up mother
explanation point and share for Lawrence
yeah well no actually it's this woman on
fire
mother explanation point and this burns
place son Lee's put back together this
house as Jennifer Lawrence rises from
the sheets and literally the sheets
energy rises up turn goes baby you know
hi you know and stuff and Xavier up
where there's there and he's like you
know oh and this you know you you really
brought me out of the flames didn't you
you really brought me out of that and
yeah I just really want to get the house
looking nice and the minute she puts her
hand on the house and you see there's a
heartbeat in the house I said this is
Mother Earth
this is either mother earth or some
proximity of that yeah I don't know who
Xavier is or anything up like this this
is Mother Earth because they don't have
a baby yet and as the story kind of goes
out they don't talk about too much yet
so I'm like okay it's just everything
she does she's obsessed with the house
looking good and looking clean looking
night she doesn't drink she doesn't
really do anything bad to herself
um and Xavier is a writer and he's
waiting for inspiration to come back he
hasn't written for a while and then
these people come over this man and
woman come over to visit and she's like
you know no what are they doing here
well we can't allow them and what's
going on what's going on and it's just
they move some things around oh you
can't die it works so hard to get this
place right this is Mother Earth this is
probably Adam and Eve wouldn't you know
it just a little bit later two sons drop
by and what and and they're really upset
over you know some financial stuff you
know a ballet let sounds like the
father's dying or something like that
and one kills the other couple sons
didn't they won't kill the other okay
I'm just getting
a while shot in the dark that the
flaming woman at the beginning is what's
gonna happen to Jennifer Lawrence more
and more people are gonna come in gonna
rip the place apart probably can't give
birth to a baby that's gonna be like
Jesus and baby's gonna die and ripped
apart or something like that and she's
gonna blow up and either it's gonna end
there as kind of like a you know I don't
know climate change thing maybe like if
you don't this will happen the world to
blow up or it's going to be
it all starts over again so yeah pretty
much from the first 10 minutes I'm like
I think this is what's gonna happen I
don't know the details but I'm pretty
sure this is what's gonna happen and it
does but here's the thing I'm okay with
it because a lot of it is done not
necessarily in historical order or a
religious order or something like that
there's symbols like you know a frog
down there kind of like the plagues and
stuff like that uh but where it loses me
a little bit is when they actually say
very clearly who they are and again I'll
giving you know again to do too much
away although I guess I can't give it
away even if you know the story it's
it's interesting to watch the kind of
Reve what different things could be and
maybe you can interpret a totally
different way but I'm saying my way the
interpretation I got I predicted the
whole thing so I'm assuming this is what
they were going for but but I say that
at the end you know she flat-out says to
Javier who are you and he says I am
again I'll leave a little bit to have
won't give it all away but I am blank
and to me that there's a couple times
where they do there was just going those
couple steps too much I felt like if you
had a man a woman there early on you
know you could interpret that as Adam
and Eve Lee but you don't know but soon
as the sun's come in and one kills the
other it's a okay well that's Kenan a
that this is Anna Minnie and she tosses
him out and they never come back and
it's like that's what this is and when
she gives birth to the child you know
well first of all the
Xavier writes his thing you know what
writes his brilliant poetry and they
very cleverly again this is smart they
do not show what he wrote instead they
visually show it you know that that's
the one thing cinematically it's like
okay you
I still are you you could do that on
stage but so they do show it in instead
of actually telling you and I like that
and it's left open to interpretation it
touches a lot of people and all these
people come to hear the word you know
they say you touch me in a big way in
seven he's even taking like ink and
doing this like Ash Sunday on their
heads and stuff and I'm like oh come on
some of this it doesn't have to be that
on the head of but but here's the thing
too
maybe maybe that's kind of the idea
maybe it's that I'm just reading it so
much as that you know that this is
what's going on and it can't be
interpreted any other way and maybe
other people could see it and see as
something totally different
I actually I didn't I don't know what
other people reading into this because
all I know is that I would sort of watch
the first like minute or two of people's
reviews just to see if they liked it or
not because again they said if you don't
want know anything about it stop here
and I did I stopped there I didn't look
into it
so I don't but they usually say like
it's really really left open and it's
not made clear and I my problem it's
it's it's it's made a little too clear I
would have liked it if we don't if they
never say at the end who Xavier is I
would liked it the two sons didn't come
in and one kills the other and so I
would have liked it if that was kept a
little bit more vague especially because
other stuff is kind of told out of order
and done out of order it's more themes
and ideas see that's the stuff I like
but even if it even if it is that as it
it's like they don't change a word or
anything like that
it is shot so annoyingly I mean see
here's the thing the more and more
people that come in then you can get
close to Jennifer Lawrence's face then
you can just follow her around shaky-cam
and stuff like that and like okay that's
supposed to be anxiety provoking but the
minute it starts it's just on her
freaking face and most of the others
aren't close up to but at least they
have some variety but at any time
Jennifer Lawrence it sounds like no just
face just face taken over the whole
frame and so when you do get to the
anxiety-provoking moment you're just
kind of used to it you're bored by it
you know all these people are coming in
and it's turned into a war zone and
stuff and gore and blood and everything
but it's like you're still just kind of
on her face and if it started off far
off and it was pleasant it was pretty
and it was beautiful anyway and you saw
stuff growing and things like that and
then as things get more uncomfortable it
got closer that would work because it's
really taking you out of it but it's
always super tight on her face and I'm
really like it's kind of like the ice
puns and Batman and Robin where they're
like no no it can't be that many no it
really is just like all entirely on her
face and maybe there's a reason for it
maybe the director had a certain idea to
have that going for it but it's like it
it doesn't come across it's not I hate
to say it's not like to okay because
it's Jennifer Lawrence that's a
beautiful person but I mean there's only
so long you can only get one face you
know in just one shot again this must
have been the easiest job for a
cinematographer every time Jennifer
Lawrence what shot do we do close-up
done me it's like all the time so so
that stuff like really bothers me I
think this would have been like for me
like a really sort of fun interpretive
film and maybe to a lot of people again
VII here there's a lot of people that
like it I totally get and I hear people
that hate it totally get that too
again as par my asshole review I'm
somewhere down the middle I do like the
way it's written III think this is a
smart clever written film that can serve
take the history and themes of like you
know just humanity in general and sort
of condense it down to this house idea
and you could argue it goes a little
overboard at the end but again at the
beginning they're kind of setting up
this is not a straightforward story you
know
everything is going to be you know well
that can't happen in real life it's
definitely not real life a kind of set
set up pretty quickly so yeah everyone
seems to have a very extreme thought on
I do have extreme thoughts but it's not
extreme love for extreme hate if that
makes sense
there are some things I I can't say I
really extremely hate the Scimitar fee
because you know when you do get to the
end and the people are coming in
it is anxiety provoking but you're just
you're kind of dumb looking at that shot
it's like one shot of her just in those
close-ups and it's just I don't know
it's film it's film you should be able
to explore do all these amazing things
and like I said maybe maybe there are
some intention I'm totally missing uh
and you know what maybe maybe my idea
that this is kind of like the themes and
ideas of humanity and as she's Mother
Earth and the Xavier II is like God and
you know or whatever you want to call
them and the baby is Jesus and Cain and
Abel and it's definitely maybe I could
be totally off maybe a director comes
out no it's not what I was saying at all
but like I said I did predict where the
story was going because I made that
assumption so I feel like that that's
not a bad assumption to make
but again the great thing about is that
it is an abstract film you can draw
whatever conclusion do you like I think
a lot of people are gonna be annoyed by
the way it's shot and how it just goes
so crazy abstract and here's the other
thing too okay the crazy abstract at the
end that's fine but it has a bunch of
people coming in and everything it goes
on way too long and I get it they want
to have the anxiety going and everything
but again you're just so used to that
shot that damn shot of her face that
when you're really dragging it out it
just starts to kind of become boring um
you know I and I get it too because
there's this scene where it goes quiet
it's supposed to be like whoa light
lights as suddenly you have silence but
like and remember in this is a really
weird comparison because it's not always
the best movie but in Titanic the dance
scene to remember where they're dancing
downstairs and
the Celtic music is going and they're
going crazy and everything and they just
have that heart cut to the men talking
and smoking and just the soft music and
it's such an effective cut and you see
the dramatic change of two locations of
this loud crazy party and it's very
quiet subdued you know people talking
very low and stuff like that and that
dance scene was like I don't know three
minutes before I made that cut I'll sue
me I haven't seen the movie in a while
but I need this ending goes on like you
know 10 15 minutes you know just people
coming in so or at least it feels that
way again maybe it's the shot so um yeah
that's uh that's kind of my take on it I
I'm wondering did anyone else watch it
and was like anyone else have my
experience that's what I'm wondering did
you just and be honest you know just did
anyone else watch would be like Mother
Earth oh it's gonna do this and if so
did you still enjoy it because like I
said I like the way it's written even
knowing that going in and not going in
but you know first five minutes I still
kind of like the idea and if not if
you're like no that's not what it's
about at all tell me what you thought it
was about yeah because I wouldn't mind
hearing that interpretation either cuz I
guess I I liked it when was more vague
if that's what I liked it more when it
started to kind of put the details in
your face and who are you I am blank
I bet see that that bothers me why why
couldn't you leave that a little bit
more open you could have the exact same
things happen but why did you have to
you know sir nail that head a little too
much but but made for a lot of people
that's fine I made they really need that
or they they either don't want don't
want to see it that way or do see it
that way or whatever so I'm interested
I'm really interested in people's
thoughts on this cuz right now it's
pretty lover hate and I completely
understand both so yeah if anything this
is kind of more of a video delight
because like I said I got the opinion
out pretty early and hopefully people
that don't wanna spoil can figure out
whether they want to see it or not
but I kinda really just want this up for
conversation for discussion which i
think is good you know what did you get
out of this movie if you saw it do you
agree with me do you not agree with me
do you think it was predictable knowing
that do you think it was too abstract do
you think it was too hammering it on the
head I'm actually really really curious
so um yeah again just kind of down the
middle I I know I'd say that so many
times so there's some movies I really
agree with I liked you know that
everybody liked I like Civil War
I liked frozen I liked Wonder Woman you
know it's like I like these movies and
everybody loved those movies but yeah
this one like this as well as can't down
the middle - wasn't it people either
love it or hate it even the reviews
we're kind of getting less and less so
I'm curious I'm curious with people's
thoughts on this so definitely leave in
the comments below because I really want
to look through Mattawa see just the
general gist of what people were getting
out of this movie and and like I said
just starting a conversation I think
this is a good movie for starting a
conversation whether you want to see it
as good or bad because there's
definitely stuff like I said I'm like
man they could have improved this or
they could have done this better but
someone else could come along and be
like no they did that because of this
and I could see a totally different
point of view so that's that's my point
of view go ahead and share your points
of view I'm really really curious so um
yeah that's about it and hopefully the
next time you see me I'll have this
chrome back so I will talk to you later
bye
you